I already winter net Bill sharp my shoes
watch out come through that door this is
great yeah they can come from behind on
this door
well what are we gonna do pretty good
building move toward phone actually this
is a pretty good building because
there's only one more in the back here
yeah it's real narrow yeah I only got
sniper the ones Emily got there my
combat axe
oh this is actually kind of cold
oh [ __ ]
hey help them help them help them did
you kill oh [ __ ]
from the top on the other side and where
am redeploying we're Gucci acute
innocence and okay let's get out of here
yeah let's get out the back here I'm
redrawing something I'm gonna make it
back to you guys and we'll [ __ ] them up
with my pistol blowing vulgar right now
where are we going let's just keep going
just keep I'm following you
let's go herbs what how come I look I'll
and even know what I think we should
slow down a little bit just get across
just apply drops over there yeah
should we go to the drop on the right
Griffin
we are a populated area it's got to be
oh my god not believe I didn't kill that
guy my shooting is just absurd
here I come I got him where I kill him
he's charging a rock at us but not on my
watch is there anything in there nothing
really
small-caliber we swimming across this
across this only neoscope holmes had
three times
this guy's got a couple of in this bag
I'm coming to buzz I'm coming to bus
cover the booze please right here don't
matter
I got a rocket for a one they want to
[ __ ] with us
all right well we're at the edge of the
circle right now yeah yeah we should we
start heading in or just stay on my mean
outskirts we're pretty good right here
well we might want to look and see what
people coming towards us see people
Northwest 333 Northwest a team of a
helicopter
Okemah Walker comes to blue you should
just Scout the blue here as it comes
towards us see if anybody's coming
Pikachu Ethan she needs why here
last thing just done yeah pika there's
people right up night coming towards us
where are they behind this tree 3:05 I
see him he's good
how's instant oh we got to go to the
final circuit going yeah that's gonna
start shrinking this I don't feel
comfortable let's go to the water let's
go in the water five people left in this
little can was your energy chat would
you stop saying that settings I know
where they were running let's stay with
that stay on the end of the circle here
that one of the buildings Mook
are the shows coming y'all there's a
extended barrel over here if anyone
needs it
I'm coming cuz I just know how to say
John though that's the reason oh there
comes a lot in front of me north north
now it's going over there there's two
guys around that corner
keep the truth yep you right past the
red wait help folder aren't there
cheese's right there where are they I'm
a few I killed one around North Norton
you're south you're facing south left we
gotta go we gotta go
I just turn on all the fur I know Java
shotguns are the worst right here oh my
god
wonder where his team is a pizzeria I'm
coming I'm coming in oh you guys that I
got an object we're gonna have to keep
moving
oh I got rid of my rocket launcher look
at all this [ __ ] no I just dropped the
whole pig [ __ ] yeah yeah usually just
yeah yeah I got it I got it
he's coming back that sums it up
Pikachu to your left yeah yeah he's
stuck in the circle stuck in the snow
let's keep moving I got your back Wow
lag yeah I just got played a search I
mean five
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
there you go crawl backwards I'll battle
back no I believe in you get up get up
there's four people left it's just Oh
number three do I got three kills did
you get that skull and then you're
crouched do you move so fast all right
let's go again like just not gonna put
Kraken I like to watch also playing with
Arthur sometimes that's crazy I know
what you mean I agree with that
yeah I can't believe I didn't kill the
guy that was all the broom I'm shooting
this they call backwards dude [ __ ]
backed up back into the zone and a nice
fire everywhere yeah
well where should we drop again yeah
this time for real oh my god what is
with the Slade Becker wait oh just lady
that turned herself black but it's like
she looks horrified because he's black
you from the UK no cuz she looks like
Scout like ridiculous size boobs and she
looks like a dude you feeling her house
dude no no no judging crack horrifying
I'm judging looks horrifying oh stuff to
say about what about you well I don't
usually want to get quadrupled deep
breaths or anything
speaking of breast size your mom does I
think she liked the pin pops did you
guys drop crazy we'll send you a picture
over no I'm good the fact we use that
thing with the pipes the pipes the pipes
yeah with the pipes there's other people
who landing here yeah they landed two
I'm going to a further
oh [ __ ] I'm not gonna make it I'm gonna
I'm gonna go there's hella people here
by the bridge
[ __ ] I'm scared not anymore I got a gun
let's go
I build one whatever you guys do don't I
live for 30 seconds it's better to
redeploy now when there's no no you can
probably seem to 1514 because there's no
upstairs right yeah this is the highest
point people can come at you through
those pipes they come at you
Griffin's over by a lot of people by you
know there's no plow over here alright
I'm dropping we're gonna come back to
you guys I can get some guns okay okay
I'm coming across come across the river
over there's like two people dropping
there next to you they're gonna pistols
where next to me dropping angry huh
there's [ __ ] I need another Johnny move
to you guys you guys here's herbs I'm
over there
screw that I'm getting out of that bill
I'm going to Pikachu on the Pikachu
we are coming in the building in the B
right yeah I came I don't want to shock
there's a sensor Dart
oh [ __ ] I think I just watched an art
there's emotional this space I think
they're in this building didn't that
explosion was the time to start
exploding so they put that up a while
later
oh my god there's so many stuff in here
come here guys there's a fast mag kind
of mag extended fast mag circle Griffin
get up here yeah right here just for
your guns magazines Oh may I steal them
although no right here in this little
box all right okay okay
why do they put a shotgun up here trophy
system kofi system that's again that's
gonna be you've that right we could find
a building to hold it up and put that on
right yeah they can't throw [ __ ] yeah
that's what you think new Chinese her
gadget sci-fi movies not shoot oh we
gotta get ya come to me there's an echo
is it clear I think it's crying
pretty sure it's crap I'm on you yeah
but you're probably watching the stream
there's a pole look at this there's a
box here
oh [ __ ] nice you came holder holder yeah
there's some guy coming up with this
tower I'm coming up - oh you gotta take
that Ludo Ludo herbs don't cover outside
he just ran up on me oh dude there's a
whole thing but there's a 4-time skull
on the Spitfire suppressor
we're good is mag yeah I'm get barricade
I found the jackpot here a bowie knife
any deals I did not mean don't done
don't Nathan oh [ __ ] don't do that hell
is wrong with a trauma kit no and I'm
stacked right now that armor is [ __ ] yes
that's 45
Oh should I need 45 travel to indicate
to the safe zone who shoot that's the
other team anybody need a yellow fake no
Gucci
wait oh [ __ ] save them save them save
them Oh get me killed one I killed one
kill them all don't worry I'm here
there's nothing that's great tenor hey
char nice movie looks pretty good no
wandering earth I check that one
yeah don't count on Pikachu to get you
up or nothing
that's cool I know I'm a lot poins cool
I worse I saw ya and Excel yeah yeah
remind me later hey just wondering earth
truth looks pretty good
what do you mean hands down loaded fired
can you help cookies love not know it's
a it's a Chinese movie about the earth
flying in the Jupiter and time it's that
picture of the woman I sent you yeah
[Music]
where we landed lighthouse you know I
liked oh my god like yeah let's go
I'm laughing at her artex crew
Cook's gonna get mad at me you won't let
him do it through the app that's weird I
mean I could do that well here's an
iPhone app yeah what hap what we're
going to the lighthouse
yeah else hey Stevie banana you have a
an iPhone did you download the pilot yet
or thingy magic no it's not gonna work
I need Windsor I downloaded them on my
phone I don't know because it's not a
have a particular program for its really
annoying winds I'm not gonna make it
windows since you're not playing me too
you should look into my iphone
application that could help him unzip it
there's kind of people just download he
doesn't
oh here we go almost shot you and my
shotgun divorce does not include native
run zippers I mean you'll still need to
roll out there I'm going upstairs really
annoying that's probably why my [ __ ]
wasn't working I'm trying to get it on
my phone really yeah that's fine yes
we're wait I should go there right now
yeah so you can yell at cranville
are you gonna shut up Arthur trying to
help [ __ ] Koki
you know what's cool about Archer though
is like if they ever cut off his head
you wouldn't have to shrink it I got a
Golden Gun I got a golden mosey
okay let's go search you there's a
disarm far away from me
I'm coming
I'm just gonna keep heading towards you
guys yeah you got a truck I see a truck
you don't want me over maybe we should
have stopped at the gas station he
didn't play a tournament the TNG Ninja
Turtle movies so I'm not that far off
right Arthur oh [ __ ] look at all this
armor plate trophy system barricade
grapple gun bend it
there's a fast mag - here we got move
move for it
I want to switch guns I'm gonna get this
a br a br yeah they're gonna cancel the
Punisher for sure boys or chat because
brick houses get ready alright wait
who's that I mean I thought you're gonna
do damage and Justin from the waves that
in disturbing this is already been
looted like a virgin right a Pikachu
please bring a couple of old ladies
maybe the evil laugh
oh I don't like seeing like you can
order that's we got it we got it
let's just get across this bridge with
these buildings - you sure oh there's no
like let's do it
hey backpack over here yeah I marked it
they're gonna push oh they're gonna come
from across the bridge economy's dead I
must add the health you shot him like
twice
[Music]
whatever you do don't die you guys 30
seconds to man Griffin come back [ __ ]
don't you already start wait where is
Craig's email right well it should be
like hey Steve go go into the building
if it's free and my body there's a fully
kitted out gun it's a swift ok what's
silencer and everything
I got here whoosh lock this body it must
be a mini run what we going where should
we go one two the circle I'm 38 let's
hit this building right here their
father's shooting right in front of us
here it's okay it's okay relax
just keep moving just keep moving keep
moving closer I'm repaying my Armour
anyways look at this is already like we
want to [ __ ] in distilling who's that
who just open that door did you open
that door right knowledge you do almost
got blown the [ __ ] up
all right here we go I could find it
like this now what I thought I made us
think the worst part that's what you
have to do you have to make like a chain
email or something
oh no no like here go Craig oh my god
here it is download file close the door
except start download right on the edge
of this building but but they don't ask
you where you want it to go there you go
there it is
move out okay I see where it is now okay
across the bridge point 25 seconds to
this game of thrones BHS intros the bomb
whoever did that did good work let's go
to this next eighty people still alive
oh I love Game of Thrones Craig that's
my [ __ ] a Tok coke but he doesn't watch
it right because reading with him or
something
well here you go okay I'm dropping right
on you guys
[Music]
Oh Griffins I am I swim swimming
I shouldn't be I'm using the proper swim
towards Pikachu
wait and shoot me I got a ball too I'll
save you guys getting you gonna get in
the bowl Oh dry the boat hey Craig can
you be IT for Coke yeah yes yes thank
you watch much banana no peeking give it
I do decked out
I love the swamp [ __ ] don't engage
10 seconds 9 all right um we're dropping
hey where could we get to them though
that's the real question
should we just triangle
I'm just circling they're all oh no we
need to go inside this mansion then one
side the mansion oh I just stopped on
the roof
mind you Griffin okay let's see if we
can find a way in by the way that's like
you know [ __ ] this is [ __ ] here's a
guy here's a tricky right weapons well
that's my gun oh [ __ ]
we gotta go
see that guy team shoots a team shoots
well oh [ __ ] I'm fortunate are you
monitoring the chat dude I got kicked
her friend just keep going down another
one behind you stop distracting me
[ __ ] die that's the downside of
deploying super late
just to see the difference well let's go
to it we can win that one now this was
more hacking kills me kills it I don't
know I don't hear holder you have
anything now I hear you guys don't hear
that I heard it four singer vulgar music
I don't hear now
person who's doing its name will pop up
when it echoes hello hey gold hello
hello
he's not back out of the chat are you
still black speak I'll back out I'll
come back in Chris you're fine I really
don't I hear it yeah I don't
I got one I got one clean up and one
down I like that what's a clean up like
you someone down them and then you kill
them what are you sir God the movie
Jeffrey okay you didn't have to be so
racist the Philippine ex-girlfriends mom
would talk about that yeah it's late
already
I think my mom doesn't talk like that oh
my god my friend my friend from my high
school he lived with his grandma so like
what time we're on the phone and when we
drop it off with his grandma I don't
know herbs you gotta choose it late jump
yeah let's go later you call out window
really right around mm-hmm so you were
on the fire your friend and his grandma
yeah so it's grandma would pick up the
phone oh I was able to download it I'm
be able to look at it you say jump
already
yeah and so like I'd be on the phone
we'd be on the phone and his grandma
would pick up the phone and then she
would start dialing there's a team
flying to turbine say you called it
really we know we're in I need some ammo
I mean some or you call it armor
Erbs you okay yeah he's good I guess
Pikachu's not good oh yeah
sometimes if it's a [ __ ] wall you
can die
dude there's a helicopter right here I
grabbed his helicopter you comfortable
applying it yeah
oh I see a guy gotta have it my sights
should I go after him I'm coming if you
go on things at once you've got a 22 I
see him he just went inside your innate
in there oh why I almost killed myself
living how'd you not die for there no so
close
he ran back inside okay I got this door
right here covered all I just saw
watching look at the girl she's in the
bikini
yes probably right is it your mom
because you're like looking into the
left of your house I just looted the
whole [ __ ] I know but I was shy him
directive I have armor and [ __ ] on that
doesn't make any sense to you five
friends bound by love or gaming I don't
like this already show ever I like this
oh my god we look so fat in these chairs
[Laughter]
I'll see you at the gaming first or you
have it going on throughout
oh this interview looks good yeah oh I
like it you have the game you threw out
Thank You Juan Cena looking up stuff
are we gonna stay on this game late or
the other one okay you go back the other
one Griffin you're still in the game I
am oh I'm sorry I was looking at myself
yeah all right I like this I'm gonna
look at it it looks good Craig hey check
it out everyone give a round of applause
for Craig no I swear to god I'll become
your stepdad just so I could beat you
every day get away with it
oh wait sorry here comes this 20 wins
that was Japan go
it makes maker with the houses I really
I sent us all did such a good job with
you have to see that game with their own
sting you don't watch Game of Thrones no
I never got into it no Ally the first
season okay I'm trying to tell you if
you would stop talking
after the first episode so I'm waiting
yeah close to the finale then I will
binge watch all of it you didn't even
want to come down because he didn't
invite you down last time
no he just lied to me I did not lie in
my defense I forgot I sent the invite is
that what everyone at court just says oh
yeah I forgot
oh gee said oh I forgot he might have
yeah CTE you know that's actually Craig
the truth is I sent him alright I
suggested that we go together
I offered to draw honestly I forgot that
he wanted he said you know my house I'm
not gonna make it
he's in the water right here next to me
he's upset because you're having a kid
and there's no really
so he was angry for heavy kid I think
that's true this is not denying you know
he's the only baby boy in your life
that's what he wants it to be baby boy
this might kill a [ __ ] somebody a
sensor dart already all right oh [ __ ] I
just gotta kill y'all well someone's
gonna comment again on the video where's
the worst graphics gameplay oh [ __ ] mom
you want to talk to Craig real quick
that's it speak to sexy here they go
yeah whoa oh [ __ ] here we go where are
you guys I'm just upset you've never
called me to get a drink we she was in
LA we could have got a mall shake oh my
god I'm in my work guys I'm never gonna
get over there to you guys well we need
to move anyways we're on the perimeter
if you look at stream you can see my mom
we got a you got a four-wheel just keep
looting
oh there's me if your health line I
can't do no that's actually kind of cool
all right here's a built some buildings
that haven't been looted yet I'm gonna
go in these buildings pick up grip
disappear got such a good kill too
anything else in this building in here
what is this rifle I'm taking this rifle
let's go back to them wait the bricks
behind us this bridge hit that bridge
let's go this building right in front of
although we got to keep going
no yeah all right so get your Tokyo
Drift no keep going
a mom moving in fast fast and for me
yeah you guys are gonna go to the right
side right side because we don't inside
the middle there and get blasted
right here right here
killed by the truck oh my god the truck
is moving yeah you still got that trauma
kit no artificial tree if anyone needs
it Kika - he's a censored art no keep it
he can shoot I just got shot from the
northwest
get the censored are too quick
watch out there might be people in this
area there's definitely people Northwest
I got shot and there's probably people
come and South to get into the circle
let's hop back in our large no we gotta
go let's go truck truck take your trunk
okay I got it
let's go everybody in this leaving no
words can't describe you stop pikachu
stop
let's go I don't have a gun do I need
some guns it's pretty good oh [ __ ] God
yeah there's a backpack in here get out
there's a backpack in here do you know
Stella you I need this gun that's why
you guys are speaking she's had to stop
for a backpack Oh ready whenever you are
just 9-millimeter I'm coming up with you
guys spell and in the next you guys go
let's go across from us
why are you honking the horn cuz he's
dumb let's stop here she always does at
this point in the game he's got a
backpack okay oh [ __ ] we're not in the
circle vote oh yes we are we're good Oh
a helicopter no I think if I'm flying my
plane to redeploy oh good the grappling
hooks way better it locks on there's a
mess for it now what's a mess mind
let's trip mine all right
ooh okay you got on the bike in the car
I didn't leave you I didn't leave you
he's lying
oh [ __ ] watch out there's westward to
farm the funds little thing is going to
that thing hey there but it's loaded
drop a weapon
you just hold a oh yeah thank you
everyone for tuning in what is it four
or five people coming up right now down
one in front of you in front okay look
um yeah who's that stop believing
everyone I have a whole minute till I
get redeploy Jesus did you pick up the
paper
yeah I did there's people to your right
2:55 at the farm
it's got ecology back this guy got
backpack I just took this guy's back
ain't head [ __ ] everything you know
this circle collapse ten seconds
oh and I got ten seconds I'm coming in
you guys gotta move the circle dogs our
backsides cover I'm coming straight for
you guys why are you going towards the
edge of the circle Arthur that's you
need to get off this island wait for me
I'm coming to you vulgar people oh my
god I'm gonna shot you getting scared
sorry see now you know how it feels
yeah there's people in there let's go
across the bridge to Pikachu let's go
across the bridge to Pikachu
yeah we got a road sign let's go road
zero difficulty what they're out there
on tape Pikachu would you wait me
Pikachu there's a guy moving toward you
know where we'll just do a [ __ ] thing
other one further up the hill 295 again
next week onam another one says will
appear left Griffin your left
oh [ __ ] I didn't [ __ ] he's dead he's
down I died there just got [ __ ]
yeah I'm getting sniped from Easton
why can't we survive that I can't
believe we survived that attack I feel
to people again we gotta keep moving
shut up oh oh that's super around stay
by a tree oh my god let's hit the first
building right here don't let another
building
who killed his teammate nice love match
9 I scan this building or not getting to
all the ways to keep moving people stop
19 people of you got this he's dead
watch the left
I'm looking around I'm looking around
Norville there's two guys as people stop
to the gather you know just in here look
Bisons yes you have a good gun can't be
do it there's some people some people
laugh you got you down
[Laughter]
what's your favorite restaurant Spain
somebody's asking so many Craig stop
talking Chat Chat I mean no stop talking
Chad you asked me to talk I know no no
never mind that's no what I meant to say
yeah my 9 kills that is a br sir
okay